i miss his comical
presence really um
it's a difficult one to answer because
there's just it's just the whole the
whole man
um
just knowing that he's there and you're
you're not going to see him it's just so
difficult to pin down to one thing it's
this
he just lit up the room he was just
always funny and caring
and comical and
protective and
he just had a real lust for life
i mean to anyone looking at they might
think oh you're dealing
with it remarkably well but what's the
real picture
for you the real picture is
you wake up in the morning people assume
that you've got
um you know you wake up and suddenly it
hits you
like a brick it's not like that it's
24 7 in my mind
it's it's a big it's a percentage of my
brain
24 7. so i don't sleep and forget and
have that feeling i wake up knowing
exactly
that he's he's not here
debbie could you um take me back to the
moment that you were told about what had
happened to andrew
um
waking up to a knock on the door
at 4 45 in the morning
and two officers were stood at the door
and they
kind of said we come in and they were
already in really
and they just told me straight out they
didn't
soft coat it which is the right way to
do it i think
um
i just just kept telling them to not
tell me
um don't tell me that because it's
it's you just don't want to hear it and
you you try your hardest not to take it
in and not to believe it and then
they're standing there then you can't
close your eyes and open them and
they're gone they're still there
but it's it's just one of those things
you just can't even imagine i can't even
explain it it's just
it's not like anything else you can ever
imagine and or explain
um your world has just changed
forever can you tell me
what you really want to see happen now
i really believe that
we need a clear-cut system for how
things are going to be in the future
if you kill or you injure seriously
injure a police officer or any blue
light worker
there should be a minimum term um
we didn't get what we thought was was
right for andrew
but we've had to go through this trial
thinking we'd be
in a different position now there should
be a minimum term
and we're looking at minimum 20 years
but with no reductions for being of a
certain age
or you know because you've you've done
your
your early admittance or anything if if
you've killed a police officer
when they're working if they're on duty
and you're committing a crime they they
die because of your actions
there shouldn't be a murder manslaughter
debate
you've killed that officer while he's
doing his job
tell me about the name of the campaign
and and
what it will mean for you yeah we we're
going to call it andrew's law
obviously a memory of andrew and his
legacy has to be something more positive
the legacy can't be the sentence that
was received
for the court case
everything that andrew stood up for and
believed in
was to do good this is the best way to
honor him at the moment
and make that his legacy something
positive that
reflects the injustice of of what he's
sadly been put through can you tell me
why
you've chosen the blue lined feather
and the particular number to be the kind
of emblems for your campaign
yeah the the number um
was his shoulder number um i think quite
a few people
know that they've seen it people have
supported um
they all know that number quite well in
their heads now
and initially we were going to use a
blue line which has been used many times
before but
i went out to give some bird food out to
the robins the other day and then i
found this amazing
feather which was just sat there waiting
for me
and it's got a big it's a big black
feather with a big
bright blue stripe going down the side
and it just felt like a gift
um and anyone that's lost a son or
anybody close to them will know those
gifts are absolutely treasured